the last training session before the
match come is only 13 years old but he's
already a fighter ma'am
I never scared I always hit hard I like
to use my knees that's my main weapon
I'm good with my knees like many at this
gym in Thailand's poor northeast gum has
a troubled family background his parents
are divorced his grandparents can't take
care of him that's how he ended up here
he eats sleeps and of course trains here
in return he fights for money our boxers
are taking part in a lot of fights part
of the money they win goes to the gym
that's how we keep things running and
how we take care of the kids
my time or Thai boxing is a national
sport in Thailand it's hugely popular
also among children but the risk of
injury is high recently a 13 year old
died after being knocked out in a fight
many parents downplay the risks involved
I think there's very little effect on
the brain if there was brain damage I
would know from the behavior change
after the fight but I've never seen that
before that's because the biggest danger
is not immediately visible these punches
are pretty hard in a real fight boxers
like gum deliver about 20 or 40 of these
to their opponent's head every round and
each time the brain suffers a minor
injury over the years those injuries add
up and that can have devastating
consequences dr. tena Paul automata has
been studying the effects repeated
punches to the head have on children's
brains
the mechanism is clonic repeated minor
brain injury it caused the dysfunction
of the brain and we found out there has
decreased memory function decrease IQ
and is this dangerous because he can
coach at school he can sing he can play
and nobody if you look from the outside
know know that he has brain injury
that's why all the parents all claim
that they don't see any thing wrong with
their kids she's calling for banning
fights for children under 12 and no
full-contact before they're 15 but in
reality kids even younger excite the
crowds all over Thailand white eye is a
deep-rooted tradition here and one
that's not easily changed it's fight
night for gum if he does well he hopes
one day he can make it big in box in the
capital Bangkok that's where the money
is but first he has to win here
[Music]
but it's not going so well for him after
five rounds his opponent wins on points
my arms weren't strong enough he was
simply better
I'm very sad I have to train harder gum
will be back another day for him like
for many youngsters in Thailand boxing
is a shot at a better life but one that
could come at a high price
[Music]